yeah okay uh thanks everyone for coming
to our final talk on hamiltonian
complexion qma uh we have Cubit who will
tell us about dissipative Quantum
eigensolvers
so it's really really nice I think it's
actually my first time at the Simons
Institute I think that's probably my
fault because I had to turn down a
couple of previous invitations because I
wasn't able to make it so thank you very
much for inviting me
um
I guess since now like you know everyone
has a spin-out company in Quantum these
days so a word about my sponsors
um facecraft is actually as research
done and it's been our company facecraft
and uh these are the co-founders so
Ashley montanaro you've heard about a
bit in the previous talk actually and
John Morton
uh they're paying for this trip so I you
know there's a Facebook policy that I
have to come dress like this as Frank
just pointed out I'm one of the
co-founders for Facebook this policy
really exists I could unmake it
um I'll leave you to work out that's a
real policy or a joke
this is I'm going to talk about these
results about ground state preparation
preparation and this is where I'm going
to go now I'm not almost certainly not
going to get to this material I put it
up there though because
the previous time I gave this talk the
audience did manage to ask enough
questions not like could you please talk
about the slides you didn't get to but
ask questions where the answer was all
right I'm going to go to this section so
let's see if you can achieve the same I
think they covered everything here in
questions afterwards
so I'm going to try and get to here
so let's start with intro to this this
is just a wrap I'm going to go through
really rapidly warm up on this because
we heard a lot about ground state
preparation yesterday and particularly
yesterday so the problem I'm concerned
with is
the ground state problem so preparing a
ground state on a quantum computer so
that input some classical description of
a Caleb or hamiltonian
each of these so leave some of the local
terms Each of which acts on at most
kudits
and then our task is to output something
that's close to the ground state of the
system so PSI Sub Zero the ground state
minimum eigenvalue eigenvector and then
we want to Output at some State prepare
some states PSI tilde that's Epsilon
close to the to the ground state I can
then rewrite this very slightly uh this
is fine if we have a unique ground state
but if we don't have a unique ground
state then I'm going to rewrite this as
and say we've got a ground state a
projector onto the ground state Subspace
and our task is to prepare some state
Pure or mixed but some density Matrix
has got high overlap with the ground
state because that way I don't have to
worry about I mean that works for
degenerate ground state as well so
that's the task repair a state that's in
the ground space Subspace or has high
overlap with the ground state Subspace
of the local hamiltonian foreign
of course this problem is notoriously
it's qma heart so we expect this to be
exponential time in worst case even on
the common computer
and
something to note is that
physical sort of physics assumptions or
conditions you can put on the
hamiltonian there's almost nothing you
can do that makes this problem in terms
of physical kind of conditions or
assumptions you can put on H the
hamiltonian that makes this problem easy
so you can if you impose that it's
frustration tree you promise it as a
constant spectral Gap commuting local
terms polynomial density of States it's
still MP hard even if you put impose all
of these conditions on the hamiltonian
Toby are you interested in the
non-uniform case of the problem so do
you get this so so so so so so so given
the the hamiltonian we need to
efficiently find the circuit that
prepares that that's right no
non-uniform complexity classes in
today's talk all right sorry Scott
um so you know this problem is purely
hard but this is a problem that people
really care about solving indeed huge
amounts of high performance compute time
is devoted to solving this problem
despite the fact that it's very
classical compute time people in
computational chemistry materials
modeling are solving this problem every
day successfully so just because it qma
hard doesn't mean we give up
and of course there's interest in
despite the fact that it's cure my heart
people have because it's such an
important useful task people have
studied many different Quantum
algorithms for this problem over the
years
um from adiabatic ground state
preparation
um the quantum phase estimation
imaginary time Evolution sort of the new
kid newest kid on nisky kid on the block
of eqe
um and all of these have their pros and
cons they're all exponential time worst
case that might work on some problem
instances you care about successfully
but there's also another algorithm that
dates back quite a while
um dissipative State preparation
so what is this this is uh dates back to
a paper by by Frank who's at the back
here Frank fuscharter of sirak from
2009.
and they actually did three things in
this paper all those years ago so all of
these results are interesting in their
own right one was engineering ground
states of many body hamiltonians one was
constructing algorithms for constructing
certain classes of states with efficient
classical descriptions and in the title
of the paper for you I think the title
of paper is something just the quantum
computation also show that you can do
Quantum computation disability so these
are three separate results in that paper
ground State Engineering as we said
exponential time works place unless the
qma collapses to bqp
comparing tensor Network States or
stabilizer States is polytime and
Quantum computation also in this model
can be is polytime uh I'm not going to
talk about these two okay so the
relevant one of those three results from
this this old paper is this ground State
Engineering Process so that's what I'm
going to talk about the other two
results are very interesting there's
been lots of interesting follow-up work
but it's not what I'm concerned with in
this talk
so for that I just need to do a slight
digression to Define what a
frustration-free hamiltonian is many of
you will already know this
frustration free hamiltonian is one
where the global ground state is also
the minimum eigen energy I uh state for
each local term individually so the
global ground state is also the local
ground state
and there's an easy argument standard
argument that for any frustration free
hamiltonian without muscle generality
and we can do this efficiently In
classical polytime we can rewrite it as
a sum over projectors so with where the
ground state is still the same so the
ground state just becomes or the ground
state Subspace is then just the kernel
of this operator the zero eigenvalue
Subspace
okay what did Rashad evolve in syrac
show all the way back into in 2009 so
they showed if we have
one of these hamiltonians that are
frustration free
then
they did something a bit more
sophisticated in this I'm going to
present a rather a simplified version of
it which which works and gets the spirit
of it
they constructed this Quantum Channel or
completely positive trace preserving map
it takes an input density Matrix and it
outputs this thing
so what's this thing doing it's we can
inter we can sort of unpack what we're
doing saying pick a random term in
hamiltonian a random project remember
our hamiltonian is sum of projectors
measure
the carry out the projective measurement
that's the measurement on that projector
or it's orthogonal complement
and if you get the orthogonal complement
outcome then just replace the state with
the maximumic state and then itch and
then that's what this map is doing
unpacked into
a very simple procedure you just measure
the local terminal hamiltonian if you
get the
um
you know the right outcome if you've
kind of projected into the local ground
space keep going if you've
um don't just randomize and resample the
qubits and the way I've written it here
we're just actually doing something very
crude we're resampling the entire system
so we're throwing everything away and
starting again if we get a failure so
you can do something smarter here but so
I so I I don't remember exactly but I
thought that that I got the pi or tunnel
then you rotate it yeah yeah this is a
simplified version of what you did you
can do smarter things than this this is
for the purposes of this talk does it
make any difference it makes some
difference and I'll come to that later
but not not big big one for this purpose
this is exponential time and services
good this is simpler to think reasonable
okay and
um
what they showed is that the if you
iterate this process
this process and you just keep on
repeating this completely positive map
this converges in the as if you in the
limit the to a state that's uh in the
ground state Subspace
okay so the fixed point of this map is
programs a ground state this looks like
a Quantum version of
closely related
um
but record it's a little bit different
because and I'll touch on sharing later
a bit it's not showing you don't run it
to convergence which is a key difference
so what's the nice thing about in the
context of preparing ground states of
many body systems what are the benefits
of this by now quite old distributive
State Engineering algorithm well it's a
simple local procedure all you have to
do is measure the local terms of the
hamiltonian
it doesn't matter what state you start
with right this is the output is the
fixed point of this process so you can
start in whatever state you like
something easy to prepare completely
random status or inexorably converge
towards the ground state
and as they pointed out in this this
paper it somehow inherently resilient to
noise and errors because it doesn't
matter if halfway through your
computation a cosmic ray comes in and
scrambles your qubits you just keep
running and it will push it back to the
ground state
the disadvantage is well it's
exponential time but that's not a big
disadvantage because all algorithms for
this problem in general have to be West
Coast exponential type but it also it
only works for frustration-free
hamiltonian so everything I said assumes
the hamiltonian is frustration free and
it's actually hard to check if
hamiltonian's frustration-free
essentially qma1 hard
so many papers working on ground state
algorithms start off by reciting this
paper and saying but unfortunately only
works for frustration-free hamiltonians
so we're not going to do that and we'll
do something
so what I'm going to talk about in this
talk is I an algorithm that essentially
is very much inspired by this this is
certificate on State Engineering which
we call the distance Quantum eigen
solver for marketing purposes
um but it overcomes essentially this
Obstacle of the distributive ground
state engineering and it works for any
hamiltonian including frustrated ones
and it has a number of other advantages
and provable provable nice properties
let's talk a question yeah why is it
this beta version not low depths in
practice
foreign
State Engineering but now it works for
any hamiltonian it doesn't require any
knowledge of the properties of the
hamiltonian so you don't need to know
know the hamiltonian Spectrum or
anything that's hard to compute about it
you just need to have a description of
the hamiltonian and you can prove that
it's fault resilient
in a sense that'll make precise later
with no overhead there's no ancillas
there's no error correcting code and yet
it's resilient to it's not fully fault
tolerant but it is an approvable precise
sense noise during the process will not
spoil the output Toby can you comment
question about why
okay well
um yeah so it's exponential time worst
case it has to be qma hard otherwise I
would collapse q a major bqp with this
algorithm but on in practice on
hamiltonians when you try it it often
runs much faster than exponentials
but that even makes sense to say that
because of practice you're dealing with
somebody who doesn't scale
you kept like in practice means in
spacecraft I care about the depth of the
circuit just the number not scaling
that's in public scaling but take the
problem care about solving how quickly
will it find the ground state of that
particular problem it's not a precise
complexity credit statement about
scaling but we'll see like examples
where it there's promise in the same way
as with vqe in practice weekly off
sometimes works well despite the fact
that the general problem is exponential
when you say any age who still means
it's a sort of local terms
yes thank you
yeah otherwise it will be a bit too much
yeah
good so what's the difference uh what
are the new ingredients here that's that
lifted this from like the distance to
grounds to engineering from frustration
free hamiltonians to arbitrary local
hamiltonians so there are two changes
instead of using projective measurements
I use weak measurements and then the
second ingredient is instead of running
this is running this to convergence
is a little bit inspired by shoning or
and reminiscent you don't run it
convergence you conditionally stop the
process at an appropriate time based on
the outcomes that you see as you're
doing the measurements so the output of
this algorithm is not the fixed point of
this CPT map this quantity iterating
this Quantum channel is a conditionally
stopped process so those are the kind of
two conceptually new ideas that get you
from frustration to a frustration-free
hamiltonians to frustrated
okay so I'll try and hopefully we'll see
I can have to want a brief digression to
adsps and then we'll come back to what
the I'll write down what the process is
and we'll start penalizing it so this is
a approximate ground state projectors
were introduced actually not in this
paper but in an earlier paper but this
this paper kind of this definition is
comes kind of from this more general
definition here this is a from from
Dorita haranov from a paper where they
proved the uh what reproved the 1D
aerial or the stronger 1D area
so this is a generalization of the
definition of agsps from that so agsp
approximate ground state projector
um so this is a generalization of their
definition
I say that an operator k a hermitian
operator K is a Delta gamma Epsilon
approximate ground state projector for a
projector Pi zero if
there's some projector pie that's close
to Pi zero in operator Norm
and for that projector Pi it commutes
with k
and K contracts
um
well let's put this on the funnel
complement of this Subspace defined by
pi it contracts by at least root Delta
and on the Subspace the support of Pi it
doesn't contract by more than gamma root
gamma okay so if this was a this was
actually a projector
um then
this gamma would be one and Delta would
be zero so very good approximate ground
state projector which would not be
approximate it would be
exactly protector would have Delta equal
to zero gamma equal to one and Epsilon
equal to zero
four ground state approximate ground
state projector would have Delta close
to one gamma not close to one and
Epsilon big
so this for those who know the agsp
results and the use of them in improving
area laws I've there's an extra
condition in the previous definitions
that I just don't care about for these
purposes which is that it does the agsp
should not expand the Schmidt rank of a
state too much I don't care about that
condition here so I've removed it
those of you know hsps it's not
Okay so
not that difficult to construct
approximate ground state projectors at
least across my geometry projectors they
might not be very good ones but they're
it's at least possible to construct them
um relatively straightforwardly so
one can show it's not too it's not a
particularly difficult proof that if I
take
this object here
what is this this is like a product over
all the local terms of some operators
related to local term in the hamiltonian
and they just add a bit of Epsilon
weight of it to something to the
identity and then I take the product
upwards and downwards this object here
is a Delta gamma Epsilon squared agsp
for pi zero where Pi zero is the ground
state of hamiltonian
what are all of these things so this
operator K sub I is related to the local
term of the hamiltonian it's just
essentially rescaling and flipping the
Spectrum
and you know this is not a very good
adsb gamma is close to one that's great
but Delta is very close to one as well
it's just a little bit smaller and the
approximation parameter is order Epsilon
squared or absolute
what's the nice thing about this agsp is
that I can implement it locally
so if I unpack let's simplify this let's
just call this thing K sub I capital K
sub I this is an operator that acts just
on non-trivially just on the same number
of cudits as my local term in the
hamiltonian
so this corresponds to performing some
kind of generalized measurement on a
small number of qubits cubits and then
moving on to the next one and doing that
in some order
so precisely this is like one element of
the generalized measurement
which is closely identity so this is a
weak measurement in that we have a pair
of measurement operators that um you
know one of them is close to Identity
and the other one
that makes it normalized
so if I if I measure all of these K sub
I in turn and I always get the good
outcome so the K outcome rather than its
complement or the other the other
outcome
I'm going to start calling this the zero
outcome so these are binary outcome
measurements not projective so zero is
going to be the good outcome because
it's zero for low energy or ground state
if I measure these things in order and I
always get the good outcome the zero
outcome then what I have implemented is
k k here Big K which we said already is
uh approximate ground state projector
of course I might fail I might get the
wrong outcome at some point in the
process and then I haven't managed to
implement this so I I can apply this I
can implement this by local operations
but only probabilistic
turns out it doesn't actually matter it
will work for any ordering
um but they don't commute so and they
said there's there's no best it's a
really good question uh it doesn't there
doesn't seem to be numerically to matter
very much but I don't know that
there might be some somewhere maybe
choosing random order
would you clarify there's still
parameters uh just Epsilon
so if I I can you know that looks like a
complicated equation but actually if I
unpack this what does it look like to do
one of these weak measurements so if I
have a k body term on my hamiltonian
that looks like a tensor product of
paulies
um then the circuit to do it you know
look has a few C knots and then some
single Cube irritations just here and
some kind of faces changing operations
yeah so you know if I if this was a two
local hamiltonian so just two body
interactions then there would just be
two qubits here and like four C knots
and a few single finger rotations it's
not particularly difficult
to implement into a circuits to
implement a single one of these
measurements and then you do this for
every term term in hamiltonian intern
okay
so if you take Epsilon go to zero does
it converge to some sort of different
equations uh
uh probably that I'm gonna only analyze
things into three types
okay that was uh adsps and how to
implement them not very good but okay if
adsps locally
so now I can finally write down what the
algorithm is so the algorithm is the
following it's going to be described by
a Quantum instrument so a pair of
completely positive maps that sum to
something Trace preserving
so this is the most General way of
character of mathematically writing down
measurement in quantum mechanics right
so one of my elements of my Quantum
instrument is e Sub Zero is just going
to be to apply this agsp and the other
one is the
other thing that you need to write down
to make this add up to something
completely positive and Trace preserving
okay so remember this this involves this
big K involves measuring each term in
the local hamiltonian ones
actually twice
so all of those measurements have to
succeed this is corresponds to like
what at least one of those measurements
didn't succeed and then I replaced the
entire thing I throw it all away and
replaced with the maximumic state and
this is not very smart you can do better
things here but I'm keeping it simple
for this talk
okay then there's the algorithm iterate
the instrument starting from Maximum X
state or any other state you like and
stop when you get a sequence of n zero
outcomes so you iterate you apply this
instrument one round of it is implying
you know e01 the instrument described by
that and then you stop once you've got
e0 outcome n times in a row
and it's not very difficult to prove
that if you do this the state when you
stop
is close to a ground state
okay indeed it's kind of the how close
it is it goes exponentially in the ratio
of Delta and gamma
I haven't said anything about runtime
this is just at the point where you
eventually stop which could take a
really long time you will stop on a good
state
one again Infinity is the whole
dimension and it's you're replacing the
whole dimension so you're
saying just at the moment I'm just in
simple cases
you can do smarter things but for now
I'm just going to switch that very
simple version
does that not to method that much
because everything's exponential time
anyway so I'm losing kind of exponential
factors in this but the algorithms
exponential time anyway so I can get a
better exponential by doing something
smarter
it's like that's the quantum version of
group or search it's also exponential
time so runtime Advantage One runtime
purposes it's just as good
um and if I had a big scalable quantum
computer that's what I would do I
wouldn't run this but that is of course
involves doing a complicated estimation
procedure it involves a more complicated
circuit than this but the this is not a
competitive algorithm in terms of
runtime everything I put on the table is
exponential time
and I got nothing against face
estimation if I had a large scale
scalable filter on Chrome computer I
would run phase estimation
I mean all the all the algorithms you
listed are exponential time but like can
you say anything more fine-grained than
that like do some and to be faster than
others I will get to that hopefully
right
I could say a little bit yeah
uh yes well no this is this is
inherently Quantum task because remember
the task here is to Output the quantum
state so it's not really uh
diagonalize it and I can find out what
its lowest eigenvalue is yeah
that term and measure it so I don't know
why you go through this AG because if
you do that
well it's fine for frustration free
hamiltonians and in some sense that is
what the original
bike but the problem is for frustrated
hamiltonians you don't want to be in the
local ground state that's the definition
of frustration that might be really far
from the global ground station
frustration
okay so it's not it's good I mean it
won't work at all it won't get you to
the ground state
um
so there are choice of many types of it
is
yeah or because it's more more robust
so there's two reasons one I want
something locally implementable which
you and your papers didn't care about
but I can still use your temperature
ones and I'll talk about that the
problem is that I also need to be able
to construct this agsp in practice
and get to this if I have time at the
end to construct your adsb a
championship following but I need to
know inspect from the hamiltonian not
only to solve the pure my heart problem
to just construct it impressive so this
one is constructable in classical
polytime
deliberately start from the state that
is orthogonal to the ground state so
this doesn't work at all
what's your place
measurement you're going to measurement
that fails at some point and then you're
just replaced with matching moves
like so in fact we're starting from
I mean that's why I put my wrote down
stuff from that to mixtape doesn't
matter if you start from anything else
that's also true in the old system s
if the maths really being State the
overlap between the maximum State and
the brown state is very small
unfortunately algorithm is indeed
that's right
you know if you have to switch off your
algorithm mindset of trying to do
something efficient here you can throw
away exponential packages at least in
doing the math this month and everywhere
okay I think I'm going to see if
you're gonna have the time to just let's
see if I can I can I will sketch a proof
of this because it's not very difficult
I mean I'll go through the proof but
I'll go through it a little bit quickly
so recall definition of adsb is that I
have a projector that commutes with my
operator cake that's close to the ground
state projector so
just taking the properties of the
definition of agsps I can just do like
simple manipulation to Just Bounce the
overlap with the ground state after I've
applied to the age of this operator end
times is at least gamma to the end and
similarly if I take the overlap with the
hormone complement of this projector pie
then I get something that's upper
bounded by Delta to the power of n
okay so that's a easy bounce to just
arrive and then I'm just going to look
at the state when I stop well this is a
Quantum instrument so I've applied e the
map e Sub Zero n times and then I've got
to renormalize
and let's just substitute in the
definition of what e0 is it's K to the N
row K to the n and K is emissions so
I've dropped the dagger here they're
divided by the trace
now
trace of the ground State against this
well I'll just substitute that state in
rewrite things a bit by turning you know
projectors into the one minus the
orthogonal complement and rearrange a
bit
and put in the bounds I just arrived and
I get to this equation
and I'm basically done because now I
just like bound I put in the um rewrite
this a bit and I've got my Delta over
gamma to the n one minus something
that's decreasing exponentially nn and
then since if I start with my this is
true for any initial State row if I
shoving the max remix State as my
initial State this simplifies a little
bit
um then I can just substitute in and I
get the bound that I came to before
so it's not a particularly difficult
proof last step this was the overlap
with the ground with the projector Pi
that's not the ground state projector my
real ground state is only Epsilon close
to that so that's just gives me a error
Epsilon
okay
there's lots of things that are not yet
I mean I haven't achieved what I claimed
at the beginning yet okay we're getting
there
um
what's really nice I haven't said
anything about the running time of this
what's nice is actually you can compute
an exact analytic expression for the
expected stop run time of this process
and it's given exactly by this
formula so this is in terms of the
operator K which you can Bound in terms
of the parameters the agsp like this and
you see here there's it's exponential
I've got a D here which is the total
Hilbert space Dimension which is
exponential and I've got a one over
something smaller than one to the power
of n which is also an exponential so
this is clearly exponential runtime as
expected but the nice thing is you can
actually get exact runtimes for this
algorithm and it's a kind of a huge
argument so I think I'm actually going
to indulge myself and go through the
proof and this is the last proof I'm
going to go through in any detail
so this is one way to prove it
um so imagine you're a betting person
and you bet remember you're doing these
measurements you measure the agsp you
either get zero or one or these you
measure this instrument you'll get zero
or one outcome
and now let's imagine we're betting on
this I'm going to bet according to the
following strategy so time step T in
this algorithm I'm going to bet all of
my winning so far plus an additional
from British so T pounds it's roughly
the same as dollars these days I'm going
to bet in all of my everything I've won
so far plus an additional T pounds on
the outcome zero coming up next at Fair
odds whatever those Fair it might be and
if I get the outcome zero then I get
back
my my stake times the odds because it's
a fair game and if I get the outcome
zero I lose everything
playing I have to pay
plus one pounds to play the next round
okay so that's a it's not a very good
betting strategy it actually turns out
it's not that bad
um okay so now let's just Define some
notation let's write x sub t for the T
the random variable that's the teeth
outcome of this process so this is this
random variable zero one and this is
another random variable M sub T that's
my net winnings at time t
so initially I start off with no net
winnings right I haven't played yet so
the m0 is zero
and M sub T well
I had to pay T pounds to play
and I bet my entire winnings and then
what I get back is on a zero outcome is
everything I put in times one over the
one over the probability winning because
it's a fair game
and if I get the outcome
uh one well I've lost everything and
it's cost me overall tea to play up to
length so I've lost two times
okay so that's just the net winning
formula so this comes this is because I
said the game had I played with Fair
odds I don't know what this probability
is but whatever it is for that round of
the game that's that's the winning the
what's my return on my bet
okay so let's do some math so if I just
write down the what's the expected value
of the winnings at time T conditioned on
all of the previous outcomes up to now
so this conditional expectation well it
divides up into the probability of
getting zero conditional all the
previous outcomes
um and the probability of getting a one
so probably getting one I lose T
probability of getting zero I win this
much which we just saw
and now if you look at this this cancels
with this this cancels with this and it
all cancels away until you just get M
sub T minus one okay so just simple
algebra everything cancels except the M
sub T minus one
this implies that my random variable M
sub t or my sequence is a Martingale
with respect to x sub T are you the
expected winnings at time T are equal to
whatever I had at the time T minus one
this is a mathematical definition of a
Martingale or Martingale with respect to
x sub t so that's just capturing
mathematically the fact that this is a
fair game
okay
by there's a nice theorem from Haskell
probability Theory called doobs optional
swapping theorem that says that if I
conditionally stop a Martingale with
some with the strategy that I decide
when to stop only based on the past not
the future
then the expected value of the stopped
Martingale is also a Martingale
so that just is that there is no way of
winning against fair odds no matter what
clever betting strategy you come up with
you're always going to in this fair game
you're going to end up not winning on
average or losing our average anything
in a casino because the odds aren't Fair
now but for my game I'm being fair to
you okay so the expectation of this
stopped Martingale is equal it's a
Martingale so the expectation of the
stopped Martingale is equal to the
expectation of M Sub Zero
which is zero okay this is all I need to
take home from this the expectation
value of M at the stopping time is zero
okay
remember now we reset the states to the
max we mixed every time we get a one
so if we've had a run of K zeros since
the last one well the state just before
with this run must have been won
so now my state
after I've had a run of K zeros is given
by this rose up K which is K time I've
applied the adsbk times and then on to
the max remix date which is just this
expression
now the probability of a zero given that
I've just had a run of K zeros is just
well I have to get another outcome in
zero outcome so I have to successfully
apply the agsp another time
and simplify that uh okay so now I have
an expression for my probability of zero
given
run of K zeros
okay I also know from the way I set up
the betting game that my winnings when
I've just had uh at the stopping time
I've just had a run of n zeros if I
rewind n steps from that then if you
think about it for a bit the definition
of betting game that's how much money I
must have that's how much I've lost up
until that point
um there's a brackets missing this sorry
this should be a plus n
I've played
T to play so far and then I'd rerun end
steps so this this should be a plus not
a minus so let's just think about what
are the rules of the betting game that I
set up
and then I can just do some math so I
just worked out an expression for this
probability of zero given everything
else this was my definition of my
winning my the winnings coming from my
definition of my betting strategy
um this is what we just worked out
before
this defines some recurrence relation
which I can now in in M sub T which I
can then solve and if I solve this
recurrence with not too much effort I
end up with this expression for M sub
Tau n and then so this is just a bit of
math solve this recurrence relation
you can see the solution to that in the
paper
okay now let's take expectations
so
this time here
is just a feministic quantity there's no
random variables in there so I can drop
the expectation
this we showed the zero and now I
rearrange
and there's my expected stopping time
so let's take and get an exact
expression for this
there are other ways of doing this you
can do this via generating functions you
can do it I do it two ways in this paper
in a different way another paper because
different proof methods are convenient
for different parts those kind of acute
Martingale argument and then you can ban
this in terms of properties of the the
properties of the agsp
okay good so it's really nice we can
analyze the running time and we find out
that it is indeed exponential time as it
has to be but we know what how it scales
with the parameters
I can run this numerically and is the
only thing I'm going to be able to say
in this talk about or have time to say
about the the fact that it's it's it in
practice it often Works doesn't take
large circuit depth so here is running
numerix and running this on a Heisenberg
chain of length 10 simulated classically
obviously
to run this on yet we do but they don't
work as well as the classic computers
um
and you see that like it runs for a
whole bunch of time actually quite a
long time and eventually this is this
purple line is the energy the dotted
blue line is the true ground state
energy the green is the overlap with the
ground state Subspace so it gets pretty
close to the ground state now this is
run for a long time but remember I set
this n equals four here so I'm only
stopping as soon as I get a run of four
zeros and before that I reset to the max
of the mixtape so the only I only have
to kept coherence for like four
iterations in this algorithm otherwise
that I'm just like throwing everything
away and restart and even in just like n
equals four it gets it it gets close to
the ground state
okay now let's just say that I've
simulated this algorithm and it does
actually work
Yeah question
from the beginning right so it's like it
runs for a very long time
keep on getting ones
or zeros yeah
it's got to take a long time
um
I haven't yet here's what I just here's
a therapy proved earlier but you know
and the stopping time this will be close
to the ground state
with these parameters but the problem is
for this to work right I need Delta to
be strictly smaller than gamma otherwise
this is not going to zero and if I look
up if you remember what Delta and Gamma
were you don't remember it I wrote them
down again these are the parameters from
the AGS local agspi constructed from the
hamiltonian
and the problem is to get Delta smaller
than gamma for convergence I need to
choose Epsilon small relative to
effectively it's relative to the
spectral gap of hamiltonian but I don't
know the spectral gap of the hamiltonian
at least it's worse than qma hard to
compute that okay so I haven't I haven't
done what I said yet
um now the solution is to not choose a
consonant Epsilon but to choose Epsilon
as a decreasing sequence in time
and so here's the theorem if I choose
Epsilon at time step T to be some
constant Epsilon zero sub zero divided
by the length of time since the last one
outcome
then in the limit of n going to Infinity
this converges exactly to the ground
state
and now this is independent I haven't
Epsilon is not depending on the
spectrum of the hamiltonian little
okay I'm not going to prove this but let
me give you sort of a very hand waving
intuition it's kind of interesting
mathematically but to sort of
complicated to put in a talk
but intuitively once this Epsilon is
smaller than the spectral Gap then this
algorithm will start to converge
and the convergence kind of goes as one
minus one over t
because my Epsilon is going as 1 over T
and this is the harmonic series it
diverges so the product of one minus the
Divergent series
converges to zero
on the other hand up until the point
where this algorithms starts actually
working if you like it starts driving to
the ground state the error accumulated
up to that point is given by something
that scales like this so this one over t
squared is coming from the fact that I
have an order Epsilon squared agsp so
you kind of pick up order Epsilon
squared error each
step up until the point where your
Epsilon is small enough to start
converging it and if you about you can
bound that by something where kind of
nice the point is it's a constant the
rieman zeta function crops up
and essentially because the error you've
accumulated up to the point where the
algorithm starts converging is constant
but then after that it converges to zero
this kind of the trade these two things
the interplay between these two things
we've got sort of tight enough control
to show that in the limit it does
converge to the ground state that's a
very rough sketch the details are in a
little bit conversations
okay
with this now I have a version of the
algorithm where this will converge to
the ground state of hamiltonian in
exponential time
without needing to know anything about
the Spectrum hamiltonian for any local
hamiltonian
good the kind of interest in the
original this bit of State Engineering
paper was the fact not that it was a
sufficient algorithm but the fact that
it was all inherently resilient to noise
in fact one of the excitements of the
reason that paper got so much attention
on the digital Quantum computation side
is it was the first model of conduct
computation that didn't satisfy DaVinci
into sorry divincenzo's five Criterion
because it didn't need initialization
you could start
so
what happens if errors occur during the
process or what happens if the process
itself as I'm into limiting tickets is
faulty so the gates are used to
implement it are they introduce errors
themselves
so both possibilities are encompassed
mathematically in this framework by
saying that I've got an Quantum
instrument that's faulty okay maybe
whether these errors come from external
noise or actually implementation I can
just Encompass this by saying that I've
got some
uh my Quantum instruments I haven't done
the right one I've done something that's
Delta only Delta close to the correct
okay
you can prove is that if you iterate
this faulty instrument until you get
around you know with the the algorithm I
just presented then the state of this
this and row sub n is then the state you
stop on that this state
will be close to the still be close to
the ground state
this is not I call this fault resilience
because it's not like full fault
tolerance fault tolerance would say I
can independent of the
error rate I can make this as close to
one as I like with poly overhead or here
I've got something a bit weaker it says
that Independence of the runtime
I the state will be the output will be
correct up to order Delta so it's like
weaker than fault tolerant full fault
tolerance but on the other hand I
haven't used any error correction codes
or fault tolerant circuits or ancillas
okay so I'm going to give a very brief
sketch of the proof of this
um
they're very this is really just a hint
and then go and read the paper I can
write the action of a completely
positive map in a kind of Matrix
representation
um this is a linear operator so I can
write a matrix representation of this
and then iterating it is just taking
powers of this Matrix
and then I use a bunch of
non-commutative paraphobinis theory and
cool stuff about the shore structure and
stuff that I don't have time to talk
about but don't read the paper because
it's nice maths and that's kind of
what's behind this proof you have to
really get a handle on the kind of sure
structure of this Matrix and then use
some fragment of
quantum paraphrabenius theory the
quantum generalization of the theory of
kind of Markov chains
okay but here's the here's a plot of
this in action so here
I have just added noise IID depolarizing
noise I think in this numerics
um at rate 10 to the minus 4.
um to this out and whilst running this
algorithm so after every gate I've
applied ird polarizing noise at that
rate
um the ground for energy is here if I
just start in the ground state and let
the noise accumulate it you know
converges to something the maximally
mixed stage and goes ends up quite far
away from the ground state if I have the
noise running but I run the dqe
algorithm at the same time you can see
that it's no matter independent to the
runtime it stays very close to the
ground state so this is the Fault
resilience in action
okay
I have to go through all the main stuff
that was quick so I can go on to the
bonus material but I'll pause maybe if
there are any questions at this point
yeah uh let's go here and then here
[Music]
they're not looking at any type of
donations
Ferry Elementary
you probably can do a continuous snap
version of this and indeed in the
original
distributive Quantum computation paper
the fact that they did it in the mostly
that paper is mostly in a continuous
time setting and you can just yeah this
week time is left as an exercise here or
anything we can get to use times so
probably a community
um so if you haven't had the property
that the maxim estate did have a
vulnerable
how safe would this be approvably
that's a really good question
um I'm not sure I think if you start
from a state with high overlap it's
ought to converge faster but I don't
think the proof and I have a little yet
if you looked at
um Quantum case set you know probably
yeah
see this coming yeah
um you know Quantum case that you have
every term is already a projector okay
so that's very nice but probably showed
that if K is 2 you can solve it in
polynomial times so does this converge
quickly
so for that you can use the original
algorithm
yourself but no I think it still ends up
being extension it doesn't do as well as
there's another algorithm that does that
okay
sorry
analysis for this stopping plane uh
goes to foreign
so the order of the operators that visit
and you find it numerically on a 1D
system is there a relationship between
the order of the terms like
geometrically on the line
um
so I cut it in 2D as well I just haven't
shown you lyrics for that for 2D Fermi
Hubbard um I don't think it doesn't
numerically seem to matter and there's
another thing you can do which is in the
paper which you can just choose the
terms at random each time and that also
works so it doesn't help to like sweep
up as opposed to not with this
resampling strategy
uh indeed in the original paper by Frank
in some of the other applications where
they're constructing uh stabilizer
States or tensor Network States or there
they use
February sampling strategies that do
something more sophisticated than does
kind of use this traffic exploited
structure and that's partly how they get
polytime
well that only works in those settings
where you've got a description of the
states
there's an interesting question I mean I
don't know it may be that for certain
things you can exploit the structure of
hamiltonian get faster exponential time
conversions by being clever and using
more information about the structure
okay let me say a little bit about that
so
oh yeah
that appears in these differences
Quantum instrument using sort of this uh
a kind of a like the circuit that you
mentioned so if I have like constantly
irrigates in those presumably this Delta
will scale with the system size
so other bonus material um because it
was anticipating this question if we
have um do the kind of stand error model
where we after each gate you know if I
play a two cubic eight targets like hit
those qubits and errors after every gate
in my circuit uh it's a little bit of
maths
um you can show that the Delta will
scale as um
uh with the number of terms in the
hamiltonian this is the local Global
space Dimension times Delta so it's not
exponential it's not scaling with the
Hilda space Dimension it's getting with
the number of terms
okay
good no more questions
of resetting the entire state
bothers me because it seems to me like
if you make a measurement that it's
crappy there you should just twirl that
and nothing else
and that is why I have this section of
the slides that I'm about to get to on
exactly what the question
I mean you might not get to hear it
to me it is also helping algorithm in
some sense I realize your strategy is
different yeah we can be within my
original table to cool algorithm too but
it doesn't have provable success
guarantees
there's some different benefits
it's great but you know so in duterte
and also these things
yes
because then you have like a sum of
local quasi local terms and that looks
like
the whole thing instead of doing local
things
I mean it has to because it has to
ask um so you could do that but I have a
feeling that quasi local is gonna hurt
because it has been the possibility of
being efficient for some problems that's
true
that's not necessarily true so the
convergence rate of this so the expect
more like shown at the moments
exponential but that's an upper bound
and what we see from the numerics is
that so that's not terrible after that
and the real it converges much faster
than the Opera this can be fast in
practice on some hamiltones it depends
on the specific structure of these the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors but
yeah I mean you can do that
um
it's gonna be exponential claims also
okay so far I did something very stupid
right if I got the wrong a bad outcome I
just threw everything away and started
again and now I'm going to get to what
Eddie wants me to say which is the why
don't we do something smarter which is
to just reset the qubits that I just
measured not all of them because why
should I throw why throw everything out
because so far what I've done is
essentially just
probabilistic repeat until success so
indeed you can do local search
algorithms like churning walks at Moses
algorithm for qll they only usually
resample locally so the qubits or bits
that gave the bad outcome so why don't
we do a local resampling algorithm so we
can do that it just changes one of my
maps
um
we can still derive analytic expressions
for the expected
um State at the stopping time and for
the expected run time it's a bit
mathematically harder to derive now
because you don't have the throwing
everything away simplifies the maths but
you can still get analytic Expressions
the expression is now in terms of D
Squared by D Squared transfer matrices
these these um
this Quantum instrument so this is like
I have an analytic expression but I have
to do a big matrix multiplication to
actually evaluate it so I can only do
this numerically now but we can do that
and what you see uh but I can't prove at
the moment is that if you do Global
resampling you get an exponential growth
in the runtime with the system size as
expected and for local sampling you do
as well but this is you get an expansion
with a smaller exponent which is similar
to like walk sat and other things where
you don't you get do you still have
exponential time but you've improved the
constant in the exponent so you see that
numerically but and this is not
simulation this is computation I just
calculated this analytic expression
might just have to evaluate it
numerically and I can't at the moment
prove that there's a smaller constant in
the exponent I can just see it is
intriguing so I don't know that's that's
all I'm going to say you have time to
say and answer your question
um but your intuition is spot on and you
can this shows that it's right if you
ran shernings algorithm it would be a
very bad idea to reset all yeah
absolutely yeah so the intuition that
locally sampling should work better it
does yeah and it does also for Quantum
the normal music
good
um another thing you might haven't asked
me about when I have a bit of time so
um I'll tell you anyway
so far I've just iterated till I see the
first run of zeros and that might take
me exponential time I know it expected
stopping time is probably exponential
but what if like I just have a budget
right I have some number of compute
credits for my quantum computer and I
can run for two hours and that's it you
know that's I got to do the best I can
what we would like to do is to stop on
the longest run of zeros that we've seen
within that time budget but of course we
don't know what the longest run is until
after we've gone and spoiled it by
getting the wrong outcome
yeah so we know the zero run has ended
only when we measure one but by that
point it's quantum mechanics the
measurement has Disturbed the state so
I've destroyed the state I would have
liked to have stopped on
so there's some nice Theory from optimal
stopping Theory again classical
probability Theory the simple version
the kind of canonical problem here is
all the secretary problems you have n
candidates you see candidates one by one
you have to decide on the spot whether
to hire that candidate or not or reject
them they never come back and the I what
your task is to have a strategy that
optimizes the quality of the the
candidate you hire and there's a classic
result that the optimal strategy for
this problem is to just reject the first
n over e natural log Euler's constant
candidates and then hire the next
candidate who's better than all the ones
you've seen so far and the probability
of hiring the best candidate under this
strategy is one over e which is not too
bad it's constant the probability of
getting the best best person so there's
not the there are other variants of
optimal property Theory but this is kind
of like the simplest
problem in optimal stopping Theory the
first one so if you use iterate for at
most t-steps and you stop according to
the optimal stopping policy which you
can do a bit better than the secretary
stopping policy but similar kind of
strategy you don't need to know what's
coming in future you stop according some
strategy based on what you've seen so
far then you can show that the expected
run of zeros you stop on according to
this stopping policy goes as log the
total time budget and that's consistent
with the fact that we expect an
exponential running time uh we expect to
need a runtime of exponential and then
to see a run event so take logs and you
can prove that you can do this optimal
stopping version of this that also
um you don't need to you can have a
version without them that you just have
a Time budget and you can still make it
work
okay uh I'm going to finish with
[Music]
um
this is a highly entangled state so I
might you know I can I maybe have only
spoiled a bit of the state and maybe I
could keep running and hoped
but
if I get the wrong outcome I know that
I've kind of spoiled the state and so I
would have liked to stop one step
earlier
so you can do other things in terms of
reasonable being clever about when
you've got the wrong outcome you can you
know the resample openly or even just
kind of heal the state and again in the
original in the different concepts
but you've but then you won't get a
state that's that's really close to the
ground state anymore you've spoil that
you've pushed it a long way away
and now you've got to convert it back
but the problem is when are you going to
stop
so the original policy is like you can
try just I'll stop as soon as I see 10
sequence of 10 zeros that's fine
but you don't know how
you know but if you've really just got a
fixed time budget you have to choose
when to stop before knowing what the
next outcome
and there's a way of doing that that
gives you the same explanation
yeah
they only go back and forth to get a
permission operator for the math
each of them these are each of these
projections
there's a gazillion variants one of them
will be exponential time in the worst
case but some might converge faster or
slower there's a lot of
language
have not solved every problem
uh about this
yeah you could do that
[Music]
there's a lot of it
let me finish with one so coming back to
the measures question actually there are
better agsp than the one I use with that
if you take a suitably shifted rescale
chebychecker so this is from this paper
um
uh then so these are the parameters
bounce to energy lambda zero Delta this
little Delta the spectral Gap this time
and now I just take I put this
hamiltonian into this chebby Chef
polynomial I get a new hamiltonian out
or this operator that I get out so it's
a polynomial in h is a Delta one zero
agsp for the true ground state so this
is very good gamma is one which is
excellent Epsilon is zero and Delta is
pretty small it's it's fact it's
shrinking exponentially in l
and for a degree l chubby Chef
polynomial I have a k times our local
hamiltonian with poly M terms so
I can locally approximate this just like
I did before I just apply the same Lemma
I had before but to this operator rather
than the the hamiltonian itself but this
polynomial in the hamiltonian and it's
still it's just a local hamiltonian
where the locality has got a bit worse
and the number of terms have blown up
and if you do that
and now instead of the process similar
process toy wrote down before but now
I'm not using a Quantum instrument I'm
just com adding those instruments the LM
says instrument together to make a
completely positive trace preserving
that but now I'm just iterating this to
its fixed point
so this now is a fixed Point algorithm
and now I can prove that this is
close
to the um
I can show that the then the fixed point
of this algorithm this is how close it
is to the ground state it depends on the
parameters of my agsp but if I put the
chebychev agsp into this formula I get
out that this is essentially very close
to the ground state this is going it's
like one minus Epsilon over something
that's you know one minus something
that's decreasing exponentially in L the
degree of my chubby chef
so this is going down this is this is
pretty good
and the proof of this just a quick
sketch but if I just the fixed Point
equation so my fixed Point has to be
invariant under the map and so that's
what my map's doing and if I simplify
the notation a bit that's the equation
I'm trying to solve for rho sub Epsilon
and this equation is a very nice form of
Matrix equation that's well studied it's
called the discrete yep enough equation
and there's a nice exercise to show this
has a unique solution and the unique
solution is exactly that and once I've
got that exact expression for the
solution to this fixed Point equation
then I can just compute and bound the
overlap of that with the ground state
Subspace
however doesn't this give a public then
this is like this will run in this will
now coverage in polytime because the
agsp is exponentially good in l
so doesn't this give a polytime
algorithm for pairing ground states of
arbitrary Quantum local hamiltonians and
collapsed qma to bqp well obviously not
because they'll be getting a touring
award speech rather than the talk here
and I'm not
um the problem is the reason it doesn't
is because you need to know if you
remember in the Chevy Chef adsp you need
to know the ground state and the
spectral Gap in order to construct the
correct rescaling of the chubby Chef
polynomial to get the good agsp
and of course to find out the ground
state energy and its spectral Gap that's
at least qma hard to compute those in
the first place so what this shows is
that there exists for any hamiltonian
there exists a polytime fixed Point
process for preparing its ground state
but it's qma complete or Q I think I
should say qma hard here actually it's
qma hard to construct that process so it
doesn't collapse
um that's the other process
um so I can't I mean I can't make this
work for our otherwise I would collapse
q a to pqp which I'm not going to do
so it really is fundamental that you
need to know the spec the ground state
energy and in fact a bit more here you
need to know the spectral Gap in order
to construct the good agsp
and it better be qme hard to do that
because otherwise
is this early for local hamiltonians or
is this for an arbitrary qma verifier
this is for arbitrary UK local
hamiltonians
all right because is there some
dependence on K in the running time uh
yes yeah
I think so the way I presented it yes I
think it'll be exponentially okay our
problem because otherwise you could just
that's right but it's there is I mean
what I presented there's definitely an
exponential dependence on k
um
the gates right yeah yeah right okay
good good no I mean yeah this is already
an interesting complexity theoretic
statement right I guess it says
something about uh advice
non-uniforms as well yes it says that
any uh ground state of a k local
hamiltonian uh can be prepared with
efficiently with the help of first time
like yes yeah indeed
um but you don't know which close time
like her right yeah okay I'm gonna end
because I'm sorry
um I'm happy to talk close climb like
curves afterwards let me just conclude
more before well before it doesn't
really matter
we can talk about it in 10 years time
slots and that will be yesterday
um okay so you know there you go this
this adds this column to this range
Suite of exponential time algorithms for
uh you know in principle qma hard
problem that might be solvable in some
instances that we care about I'm going
to say because there was a lot of
interest here yesterday and day before
on Gib Samplers I want to just flag but
I'm not going to have time to say much
about it at all a follow-up paper by by
danzan Jan Lucas Borgia and myself
um was on the archive just a month later
than the paper I talked about and we can
build on these ideas to construct a
disability of give sampler and the
algorithm is almost identical to what I
already presented the only thing that
changes is the stopping condition you
now change the stopping Edition to
probabilistically stop depending on the
sequence of outcomes you've seen the
analysis and proofs are quite different
but the algorithm is almost the same
thing
similar benefits to dqe and simple local
procedure it's you can prove it's fault
resilience there's no complicated
subroutines like phase estimation
involved or time Dynamic simulation or
hubertization you can get exact analytic
expressions for the runtime no kind of
mixing time parameters hidden in there
um it's I think got optimal
scaling runtime scaling with in terms of
the Precision or at least it matches
previous algorithms I'm not quite sure
about the arguments of why that is
necessarily optimal
in some sense it's a closer in spirit to
just the classical Metropolis Hastings
algorithm for Gib sampling classically
you're just doing Simple local updates
at each step
the key difference is it's not a fixed
Point process we're not and this is in
some sense how we're able to do this
where previous local
Quantum generalizations of metropolis
Hasting had to go via very different
routes that look very different to the
classical one the key difference is
we're not using a fixed Point process we
don't run the quantum Markov chain to
convergence we construct a conditionally
stop process and somehow that's what
allows us to do this with this kind of
simple local updates rules rather than
needing to use spaces
downside I think this algorithm this our
dissipative give sampler I think it's
sort of inherently exponential time I
think there's no unlike with the dqe the
ground state case I think there's no
hope of this working quickly on certain
hamiltonians but I'm not 100 sure on
this because it's a bit too recent I
haven't thought enough about it but I
think it'll just always be exponential
time you just have to live with that so
it's not where's some of the other
algorithms like the one from yesterday
potentially could
mix faster than the theoretical levels
okay uh
Outlook
what I like and the promise of the the
reason that the dissipative grounds the
engineering just the quantum computation
attracted so much excitement over a
decade ago is because it's kind of the
main selling point is that it's felt
resilient without needing any overhead
right the algorithm itself is kind of
resilient to errors and self-correct
and
that's very useful for companies like
facecraft where we're trying to do get
stuff to run on this devices because
without any overhead we have an
algorithm that's kind of self-correcting
so baking in the kind of Correction the
algorithm itself seems a promising thing
to do and we're nearly there and there's
almost Quantum Hardware that's capable
of running these algorithms not quite
because you need to do intermediate
measurements and feed for but it sort of
it exists now as of the last couple of
years
I'm just relaxed
we're always hiring smart people to face
crops I'm going to end there and thanks
a lot for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah yeah let's go Frank first and then
slide who said that you had a local
update but then I don't understand that
what you said was it was like a global
update no because you have to do the
measurements and they all have to
succeed
um
the so you're measuring the local terms
and then you can resample locally and
then you move on to the next step
in that sense
obviously you have to do something
globally because the give state is a
global thing but each step is just a
local you're only operating on KQED
but it's a very different algorithm than
the one we've talked about in the
this is the
um
no I think I mean you're right it's it's
you're right it's probably I should
rephrase this um you're right it's not
local updates I'm local measurements but
then I do a global update right you
replace with Max remixed
that's true
oh my God
okay so the question is does the
polarizing model give the colors
uh it's it's just sort of a standard
noise model when doing Theory stuff
um it's not I don't have there's no
particular reason to think that it would
be depolarizing noise it's particularly
nice so this should work please
yeah so the proof is for any noise model
I did the numerix with idd polarizing
because
ethereum shows that it's resilient it
doesn't independent
yeah yeah I'm trying to think why
um
that slide doesn't my qcma course
like someone could tell you what time
does
the issue
I know I think but then you need advice
right so I guess it's something the
advice could be the energy and the Gap
yes but then you need right but I guess
that says something like qcma slash poly
is contains wait really really I don't
know I need to think about this more I'm
not sure
we should discuss the complexity Theory
implications right I mean if you just
described the circuit right you have you
have an algorithm someone just says
check oh oh wait a minute but it's it
it's a fixed Point process that's right
so it's not an efficient algorithm to
prepare the state it's just a process
that would have that as its fixed point
right
I need to check the expected runtime of
that okay let me I think if if if it
were polynomial time then qma would be
contained in qcma poly which would be a
huge deal
it's not quite a touring award but it's
a you know
what's the low entering so early yeah
yeah but the reason it's advice is
because you don't necessarily trust that
the best
perspective but
if anything why
why
so why do you need advice ah you need a
spectral Gap
which obviously it's for gapped
hamiltonians I see yeah yeah you need
you need you need the spectral Gap so
the ground state you could verify but
the spectral Gap you can't right that's
in qmae to the no some
uh
yeah
um
I think uh
uh that just says that you've got a
description of an algorithm to prepare
with advice to prepare the you know a
SAT assignment but that's really trivial
I just I'll leave the assignment and
which bits the flip right it ends up I
think the classical is kind of trivia
correct
what do you mean by polynomial sizes the
ground shade
California
I think so but I don't wanna I need to
check the complexity Theory implications
of this I'm not sure that depends on the
poly runs expected runtime of the
consideration check s
what the implications are
yeah we're just clarifying what exactly
is the claim about which I'm not making
any claims because I need to think more
about it
right
yeah yes
does this mean qcma contains
that's right yeah okay so because you
need the Gap I guess the thing
underneath
I don't think so I mean this album is
right it's like a nice piece of theory
but in practice and it's an exponential
time and that really hurts like
the I don't think it's the most you know
I don't know how reasonable this
algorithm is for near term at least in
the form I presented the exponential
type X-Men time algorithms are really
painful right and this is kind of as I
said sometimes it does converge quickly
but also sometimes it just really does
take exponential time and you really see
that I mean I mean you would just have
to pitch the non-uniforms
if you've got some non-uniform investors
that are happy to take advice from you
Scott let me know
estimation
phase estimation yeah I mean the naive
Brute Force algorithm
Quantum generalization of naive group
for search is not very naive it's two
phase estimation with an actually mixed
input on the right and then you know
measure the the output to collapse it
into an eigenstate and just repeat until
you find the ground
you perspective
uh
I don't that's a good question I don't
know I think there's some hope in the I
mean this algorithm framework that I've
put together if I apply it to sat and I
do the local resampling
and you know I choose my stopping
condition I guess this is a special case
so in that case yes
but you're asking a different question
and I don't know but maybe with the
local updates it's possible you're doing
slightly better but I think it will be
problem dependence and it might it
probably is dependent
yeah
yeah I mean it in the general framework
of this where you can you know a lot of
some a lot of the analysis present a
kind of simple version but this a lot of
analysis Works independent of what
resampling map you put in and what in
particular the resampling rule and the
stopping rule so one case of choosing
those gives you churning
um other cases gives you like Moses
algorithm but you have to then choose a
better you know a smart resampling
strategy and a stopping rule that are
appropriate to the problem
so if you suspect this is strictly worse
than doing phase estimation on the
maximum State like there's no
um I think it depends on
um
that's a good question
um I mean It's Tricky worse in my terms
because I don't want to have to run a
phase estimation
algorithm
you mean in terms of runtime sure yeah
um so I think it will be the upper
bounds of pro I think or worse but
um if you do the local recycling I can't
prove it but you get you know an extra
time but with a smaller constant in the
Improvement in the constant and that
might do better but I don't know I mean
that's not a proof and I can't prove
that that's even true that you have a
smaller exponent they can just see it
numerically
so it's possible with the local local
update up type algorithms you might do
better
are there other algorithms that do
better than famous imaginary time in
English
there's a lot of algorithms
the interest that I have in this one is
the Fault resilience plus the Simplicity
of it compared to doing a whole phase
destination
should we take the rest offline maybe
thanks
[Applause]